[Music]
Kurt Metzger Jacob too much who else you
interviewing here
are we on you thinking we're on right
now yeah I just want to go and get the
time sign oh yeah yeah who else he
interviewed so far Aries Spears more
Normand human dude okay yeah he did it
come week so he was here at the Laughing
Skull so he did that was a good one it
was like the week before his special his
comic signal special Aaron yeah and he
just I've had a couple of comics talking
about like how hard it is to be a white
male comic now who was there was a
Andrew Schultz mentioned it mark Normand
mentioned it Jared Harris another that
mentioned it just how there aren't
really looking for white male comics
anymore well I mean who's they yeah but
you know when I moved to New York that
was the first thing I was told by like
Lois Schaeffer who was the Booker at the
Boston Comedy Club they're not really
looking for white male comedians I still
don't know who they is that's like an
ongoing thing and and but now what it is
is like I don't really have a problem
with that I don't need anybody to look
for me mm-hmm you know but there's a in
entertainment there's a particular thing
of like weed to actively kind of [ __ ]
him up now I know it's it's
entertainment very specifically
everything that traditionally was like a
black gay thing you know I didn't know
that well it's just like from old days
like that was a place where you could go
freely I don't mean like you know I
carry Belafonte had to go in through the
back and all that [ __ ] but I just mean
like entertain was performing was like
look down on is like something like that
blacks and homos do not officially okay
that's why I like we hear about
Shakespeare times the man always played
the parts of women because no no woman
would be in the theatre because that's
like sword a didn't you know oh well I
know now yeah I've never heard that no
well it's just a team it's a place where
it's like you know the freaks and
liberals go
generally so if I was like dumber than I
am
I would probably imagine that there was
like a [ __ ] plot to get white men
it's not that there's not but it's not
like a real the majority the country's
like white people so yeah it's fine in
real terms like it's not like what a man
can't make it it's all like that
right I just don't want people to
actively try to [ __ ] [ __ ] me up based on
my gender and skin color you know I mean
like that's that's what bothered me you
want them to mess you up
based on your opinions I understand why
there has to be any kind of like
punishment for having the wrong opinion
like I'm pretty you got if you got a
better evidence for your position in
mind I'll go to your position but you
have to have it you can't just [ __ ]
shame me into it or [ __ ] bully me
into it like I'm not or it's like well
the group feels this way I can't I don't
respond to that I guess we're comedy now
though there is a [ __ ] thing of like
it's a stupid man because if they really
were into like diversity you can find
talented people of every I mean like I
could tell you flat out like non male
non-white people that are hysterical
that you would be great on something
that they're not nothing's happening for
them with like the business is looking
for like demographically correct one guy
called it and it's like yeah there was
we want like black people now but it's a
very specific kind like it's like Donald
Glover type of backpack on [ __ ] got
gently afro or glasses so it's still the
same [ __ ] it's just like same [ __ ]
different color it's not like actual
diversity they don't want like a black
person who's black like they want a
friendly stereotype that people already
are comfortable with right like the fat
black and sassy check gotcha
so it's it's like [ __ ] it's all
[ __ ] it's not what Norman in
particular I think is [ __ ] up because
they didn't want to do his hour unless
Amy Schumer liked to put her name on it
oh that was like the agreement is unless
Amy put our name on it
Marc told me like he couldn't get it
that's outrageous that cuz Morgan's very
talented man yeah coming Central
especially like Marc has the chops and
he [ __ ] pay dues and people want to
see him so they're [ __ ] up for that
but they don't look at it from the
business
but hold on ringtone yeah I think if
you're like liberal in particular it's
like I'll just focus all my bile at one
group that it's okay to be to blame
including my own problems I know it's
it's not anybody these things funnyman
if you talk about that like they want to
get what males like it's not like black
people or something it's it souls
exclusively like young white women or
dudes that are kind of white women you
know it's being so opinionated something
you've always been ours that's something
you kind of acquired from being around
like Patrice O'Neal a lot and stuff I
mean opinionated sounds like you've got
like I'm not sick I don't have like a UH
like an ideology you know I got I mean
like I would be a flip-flopper in a
heartbeat if like I said if you got a
better if you got some evidence to
that's that means I'm wrong about
whatever I think I'm down to hear it
yeah because I'm so anti like from being
in our religion uh jobs witness yeah
think that I I see the pattern over and
over again everywhere I go so there you
know did the [ __ ] you hear now is this
specific like all that like privileged
[ __ ] and all that that's very specific
kind ideology that you have to believe
for things to even get to those points
that they believe you know
well yeah position of privilege where
you'd be broke in your position probably
like like okay we'll explain that you
have to have already accepted like
twenty premises that they accept the
people who say that he's make it's like
Scientology it sounds like here it's
just like that I mean it's like Joe
witness that we for you you're like Walt
you're Joseph some like nice things
about them like they're not political
and they don't believe in like Hellfire
uh-huh
what to get to the nice part you got to
swallow a bunch other [ __ ] you know but
you are Dane day like seventeen yeah
well every Joe is witness that gets
baptized and official is technically a
minister I believe the reason they do
that is so that you can get a deferment
if you get drafted
you can't go to war you can't be a
Christian and go to war so that's that's
I think that's the idea behind it and
then also the people knocking on your
door is that's that's what that means
we're games right a little card I guess
it's like technically I could have
performed a wedding somewhere if I had
to it's not like I know people are
surprised that like you were minister
like it's not that hard to love your
teens isn't it's a made-up thing it's
like being a dungeon master like it's
not so you completely turned off from
religion now after all the percent yeah
yeah you don't even believe in God what
is that Stan Oh sometimes they do
sometimes there oh yeah I don't have any
like hard position on it agnostic I
guess would be my thing but from what I
read now that you're like an atheist if
you don't like agnostics like not kind
of the accepted term according to
nitpickers I guess uh-huh
it was like atheist this means you don't
have all God that you worship so I don't
know I don't know what there is I just
don't know that's where I leave it out I
heard about to go in will uh you know
pause it to everything is that how it
goes uh I'm late a lot to things yes but
I have a lot of [ __ ] going on it is you
do when I got like three things going on
I'm not an organized person so I guess
that would help doing growing up doing
so many urban rooms did you understand
time on that scale yes funny man oh no
my therapist had some kind of defiance I
don't really know why I didn't like that
but my mother was like that I inherited
it yeah I don't know I'm not I got in
this business to be a jerk-off I'm not
like professionally so to be a jerk-off
yeah I don't have a job
oh yeah so it's kind of like more work I
don't know I thought I was always lazy
but it's not that I just want to do
something I'm interested in so it ends
up being more work time to avoid the
work you didn't want to do right but
anyway the white guy thing is I have no
problem with it because I I hope that
the stereotype is like white male
stutter named Kurt Metzger are not funny
because that that's to your advantage
that's what I like about the black
creams like they really got what's this
kind of
right right it's like store now as a
female comic basically so but that's
that's good because the bar is so low
you're like flying when you yeah over
the very low expectations like I got a
problem with that I'll do a lot of I'll
do a lot of urban rooms too and they are
the expectations are so low you get a
break just for showing up really
sometimes sometimes people like you on
I've been everywhere so some spots are
like hostile but the good thing if you
start out with doing like all black
people rooms is they'll will show up to
an open mic a crowd not a bunch of
comics crowd of people will show up so
but something that's like kind of just
like nice in general a black people
don't go to like do you know like the
beginner talent thing like they like to
see that like you like the Apollo
amateur night you know right yeah yeah
the thing of like if they Bowie or
something that's not you know you're new
or you're like freita but there's
something about that that I I have like
a lot of affection for like that it's
like fair to me mmm-hmm so even if they
pull a gun out on on you I remember my
first night somebody pulled a gun out
put on their table in front of the host
uh-huh you better be funny [ __ ]
and then was to read Gordon and Philly
was the host and he was like going and
then cops came like two minutes and got
this guy out of there oh yeah I think I
tend to shoot someone I think he's just
being like an idiot yeah yeah but that's
terrifying
Julie's like that Phil he's like people
that's stupid they don't think ahead
what's your best abou story getting
booed on stage the one that pops out in
my head I don't know man I've had a
[ __ ] I really like the first eight
years of comedy I'd have liked a
meltdown once a year somewhere with a
Kramer meltdown but with like obscure
races you never heard of I didn't even
know who Guyanese people were until when
I started coming but uh it was at the
comic strip and I was it was packed on a
Late Show and I did some Joe I did a
joke that was like the first joke I ever
wrote you know it's like it just sucked
and I just and I saw this thing when I
wouldn't be doing well like my I would
try to see how bad it could get almost
oh yeah lean into it yeah which is not
it was kind of a perversion of a thing
that you should do
stupid of me but it smells good word I
guess but I I would be like oh you don't
like that we'll all be as [ __ ] big a
piece of [ __ ] as I can mm-hmm you know
like so I but this is the first joke I
ever wrote and I said it and I go like
when I was younger
there's this guy in my block named uncle
Charlie that you said molest me every
day and he said if you tell anyone what
I did to you I'm gonna kill your parents
and then I told everybody you never
killed my parents
I thought we had a deal dude that's my
first-ever joke I wrote I know it
doesn't sound like I mean sounds like
something what problems wrote that so no
doubt which you are that didn't win the
crowd right that's like my it was like
my parachute and a bad situation is like
Bugs Bunny like just Forks or knives
come out of the chute you know that's
what that was
I know people blew me so hard that when
Asian guy stood up and did like an
Apollo like with his fingers like whoa
you know you [ __ ] up on a Chinese guy
he's doing that so but I mean I might
had a words bombing out but that one in
particular just six out of my mind
because of how bad it [ __ ] me up for
like two months I was like gun-shy and I
was already doing comedy for like three
three years or four years so it's not
you know when you're beginner you expect
it I mean I still be good on three or
four years but it probably hit harder to
me because I was a little bit further
into comedy mm-hmm and it was like I'd
stuck with me like just the pain of that
but uh be like oh I better go back to
art school no I just it was like this
[ __ ] just sad like I don't know man
it's like a losing a fight or something
feeling like yeah but uh you know that's
being a [ __ ] so matures good for you I
mean it's like you should have as many
of those as you can so that when you
have that situation it doesn't like well
last night for example Late Show it's
not bad crowd like oh I love that thank
you like people very nice out but you
you were all man they had dead [ __ ]
energy and I'm like what the [ __ ] and
then you're getting that thing where
you're it's it's almost like an economy
like I anytime a crowd has a fair
economy like okay laughs for joke that's
fair enough
mm-hmm anything like no I'll have to
have two extra jokes for more less you
know and it's like an unfair
yeah that's that's that's draining you
know stay in there like what that's why
I've noticed and watching this weekend
is like regardless of the reaction like
you don't a lot of comics would be like
what's wrong you just stay in there you
just stay swinging like you don't kind
of lean back and like try to toy around
well that's the thing man that's the
difference I would say when I started in
like now because I'm like 18 like 18 or
19 years into it yeah how good you are
is like how good you are when that
happens right okay how good you are calm
it's not when you're killing and the
crowds nice whatever it's like when they
suck like what do you do and that's how
you judge how good you are you know
uh-huh
so I'm Darrell Hammond I used to watch
at the cellar all the time and uh he's
really cool guy that guy and uh I
remember like Marin like Marion we were
in the stairwell watch him and the crowd
sucked
I remember Mary's like nobody walks
through the [ __ ] like Darrell Hammond
he's [ __ ] right
like Darrell Hammond we like he wasn't
killing but he was saying [ __ ] that's
funny but it was just his you know he
was just like gliding over the [ __ ]
[ __ ] River like it was like a like
that's like a pro you know no doubt so
so I wanted to be like a pro so just
that is because you're like kind of a
vampire and you're feeding on their
energy and so the first thing is like to
learn it in columns like what do you do
when they're giving you nothing and you
have to bring your own energy to be able
to like get them to give you some and
then get your engine going
mm-hmm and then with the light crabs
mothers ones where it's just like a slow
like somebody punctured a hole in your
gas tank it's you're slowly leaking fuel
so you've got to keep like gathering
your [ __ ] Chi or so I don't know what
the [ __ ] but you gotta like keep like
barreling through like that and that
does I think that's like the hard part
to learn but the way to do it is like
like I have like love for the audience
so when I started the way I would I
would get there was just think think of
them as animals that are not off stage
on stage I'm very grateful he came to
the show blah blah blah but on stage
it's like well you're a bunch of [ __ ]
stupid animals I had to pay someone to
make you laugh because you're so unfunny
and students you can't do it yourself
and I'd have to think that way to feel
confident enough to do my set but then
what happens if if
if you get uh somebody sucks in the
crowd it's not when you if salmon
bombing I would never would've lost I
never lose my I'd never would like lose
my temper but it would always be I was
doing well and then one person decides
to [ __ ] with me
it's like unfair and then that would
make me angry or if heckling I don't
have any problem with you want heckle me
you know my crazy Joe drew wolle from
Seinfeld like I like to leave the door
open to encourage intruders mmm-hmm like
I can't make a show out of you that's no
problem but uh a dismissal like someone
talking like I'm not there
we're like waving their hand like go on
like that like that used to [ __ ] in that
was my little like snap and the Kramer
breakdowns on those yeah yeah and that's
like that's the thing like that I now
don't have that like because I have like
love for them so the way I always it
looked at as like on stage I'm like I'm
the [ __ ] Kim jong-un dictator of this
Ronnie wait [ __ ] it's not a democracy
it's what I say it's gonna be mm-hmm
because that's what they need you to be
is like in charge because they're
following your cues so if your energy
that's the reason you got to bring some
of your own energy
that's all I picked her from all black
rooms is like I've seen it's I would be
like some kind of like low energy
alternative comic by nature probably had
I not had that that experience of seeing
people perform perform exactly and it's
very similar to like I don't know if
like Jeff Dunham kind of not Jeff Dunham
ah um Jeff Foxworthy though what do they
call one of your favorites
ya know Jeff Dunham was when I was he
when I was young that was my favorite
when I was a kid amazing Jonathan was my
favorite uh-huh but I mean we used to
love Jeff Dunham when I was like 12 hey
by the way back then I think it was like
his show was funnier then now it's like
a little more Vegas just like
stereotypes and I don't even ever
promise stereotypes if you do it funny
it's just like right it's not whatever
it's not serious just done it was just
like I remember it
I don't when I was 12 I remember that
jalapeno honesty like I know I was the
funny [ __ ] I ever you know and I wasn't
like a 12 year old that loved Richard
Pryor or loved whoever you're supposed
to magicians and puppet people people
tell you to love it yeah like I was a
kid so I and I still have that kind of
feel like the people that are like the
greats that you're supposed to look I
appreciate them from doing it
like I've been onstage I'm like you know
Richard Pryor was a guy in movies when I
was a kid so I was never against Richard
Pryor or something but I wasn't ever
like oh my god he's the greatest like
even now if I watch it I'm not like I'd
rather watch like Dave Chappelle or
David telev and watch or Richard Pryor
old one but cuz I do it for a living I
can appreciate what the greatness is of
what he data it's like like wow that's
like a shoulders you stand on you know I
mean there's the shoulders of giants you
stand on now you are friends with the
Giants though it's incredible yes I like
that about comedy you get to meet people
that are like you looked up you know
yeah I'm like you know I meant like
legendary weird at the [ __ ] laughs
house and he was the host I was like oh
well that's because it was like all
people I saw him like evening at The
Improv kid and thought about stand-up
yeah you bet somebody discovered like
kind of stand-up comedy whatever I
didn't think I was gonna do it but I
liked it a lot and I liked I was like an
unhappy kid so I was like I liked
laughing so you started with Kevin Hart
you guys were like you pretty much like
started a week before him yeah it was a
big Jay started six months before me
that Club and Kevin story two weeks
before me I think it was like the king
of it for out of the gate Connor you
know really yeah he was always keV like
he wasn't it's not like he changed or
something he's always been the same
exact dude mm-hmm
I know like very like you just had like
whatever it is like you I met a couple
people that like you know I met a me
like those people I met I'm like oh they
have like it like the thing where you're
gonna be famous and you're gonna be like
a movie star just like an energy thing
or like how there is well yeah not just
that but there's a certain kind of savvy
like a business savvy uh-huh I know
[ __ ] I don't know it's an impressive
thing like I got I didn't gave a [ __ ]
about any that kind of [ __ ] like I
really like stand-up and I wanted to be
like a really funny stand-up so like
like I tell was who I was always like
obsessed with like being like you know
or nothing patrisse like that was my -
[ __ ] who I was like stealing from oh
well influenced by I guess but you know
I like jokes but I was like trying to
eat what they did and then hopefully you
grow out of that you know everybody does
that you have somebody that you're
trying to be like of course yeah my new
face is that I did in Montreal you
ago I don't know if it's online or
whatever but if you see that looks like
and I wasn't even aware of it but my
friend buddy bolt was like man you sound
like I tell a lot and I'm looking at him
like she's on it but I didn't notice
because I've been hanging out with him
too and it's like very hard not to talk
like I tell if you hang out they tell
it's like in fact I was like get like
catching the Attell like all it like
it's so easy to slip into because such a
fun like know like it's so fun to do and
he's like so goddamn that do like I've
never seen anybody like that that takes
all their emotions and channels it into
being funny so if he's angry like the
angrier he is the funnier he is so hey
just crazy like I've never seen be like
if you watch a tell I kind of seen it
he's won a few people I would like run
to watch he's unstoppable
he's a force yeah yeah so I know like
the high and low end of a tell on stage
when he's like doing great and whatever
anyways up but the way to see him is
like when he's a little bit pissed off
mm-hmm like when somebody crab pisses
him off me and that is like when you
gotta not leave the room and make sure
you watch cuz it's like the funniest
[ __ ] you've ever heard the energy drain
thing I'm talking about it for some
reason that that triggered something in
him that it's like he just gets bigger
and bigger and it's like he also can't
be as he was funny man like if you're on
stage with him I tell is not like a he's
a really generous guy I don't not
talking about like something money or
somebody he's not like a generous person
to be with on state like which sounds
like negative but is that like you'd
never be as funny as him on the Gulf the
cuff so it's just fun even if he's not
letting you like shine mm-hmm it's still
like a reward people go on stage of them
all the time or like if he wants to have
a banter with you like you I don't know
I never really saw anybody like him like
it you get like it's a privilege to have
him step on your ship yeah way better
than anything you would have thought of
yeah and you get to be entertained -
mmhmm whereas somebody else you were
doing that with you might be annoyed at
or whatever he's exact obviously like oh
good he's like stepping on my cuz I feel
like I was inadequate and like how much
like professionals yeah yeah like I got
fired by Seinfeld on don't cry warm up
once and that's like kind of like an
honor you know like fired by sign film
yeah
well my shitty crowd won't look but um
uh-huh
you know it's like a thing I can say
that like it's only fields mean it's
unlike that just like oh it's like it's
still like cool to me that I could like
know people or have a story like that
yeah I mean you've seriously worked side
by side with like legitimately like you
said the Giants of the game I mean like
Patrice O'Neal Dave Chappelle louis c.k
like Amy Schumer what are some lessons
you have learned from working with
really the best to really ever do it um
it's all the same [ __ ] come on okay
listen
and also like I put this well one you
got no control over anything in this
which is in general you really don't
have control of anything but you have
your set you control like you control
your jokes that's the one that's what's
cool about this it's like you have total
control over that so if you don't like
anything like that you know like they
don't want white males thing you're
talking about to be getting like you
can't control that like that's just how
it's in vogue right now and if you
happen to be the one that some
Millennials think is like their punching
bag then that's how it is but you
control how funny you are so like looks
like it tells like it tells like I just
want to be as funny as I can bake right
that's how I feel like I want to be as
funny as I could possibly because I
remember when I first saw like ham or
like other people that are [ __ ] great
I remember from Philly me and Jay were
sitting in the crowd at the cellar and
like you know it was like we're they
didn't know we were and [ __ ] so it's
like it was hard to just what color can
I sit down you did like know somebody to
even just sit down cuz I have any money
to buy two drinks or whatever you know
mm-hmm um he's doing crowd work and it
was so [ __ ] fun I mean we were like
in tears man like we didn't know it's
like we didn't know you could be that
funny well he was never my favorite from
TV I didn't think bad of him but he
wasn't like my favorite you know until I
saw him live on sounds like Jesus like I
know I just I don't was just the thing I
didn't know existed like of doing it I
know so that I guess that's the many
things like like trying to be like as
funny as I can be and then that helps me
a lot
you know you like I said if it's in
vogue you know it'll be women are funny
was in vogue for a while as the flavor
and now it's like only women are funny
it's the official line but all that's
horseshit like like the car if you're
funny man
you're gonna get something out of this
and you're gonna be able to at least
live doing this if you're truly funny at
it now you might not get cast in things
okay or being a movie or something like
that's I think people confuse stand-up
with acting work a lot when they talk
about not getting a break or you may
never get that where the industry picks
you well oh it's your time to [ __ ]
have a deal and whatever like so if you
think that way you're gonna set yourself
up for disappointment
mm-hm but if you just funny at what you
[ __ ] do no one can [ __ ] take that
away from you even when they're [ __ ]
trying to like they want to ruin your
life or that media [ __ ] I had where you
like so he wants like slander you or
make you into something that you're not
Andrew and nobody bothers to talk to you
about it they could do it without you
you don't have to be present for it it's
not the thing well I told ya I told it
was a toy Tory was okay cuz I didn't
want her to be pulled into some [ __ ]
right but but I mean I Louie CK takes me
like listen man don't sweat it like the
tirmidhi just made it like a jillion
dollars off your name right now mmm but
they don't get to say who you are and
they don't get to define you and all
that [ __ ] mm-hmm which is good they said
to me because it was really upsetting
but you still can't like even like
whatever the most vile of some someone
who doesn't know me that thinks whatever
like you can't take away from me that
I'm good at it like you can't and if you
are you're not being honest so that's
what you got that's all you [ __ ] god
is that and that's why I learned from
working at those people that I looked up
to is like that that everything else
walks like that's the [ __ ] that talks
and you don't need the validation of
like the industry or 1/8 I always see
people obsessed with like getting a
manager get an agent or getting on
Comedy Central
we're getting like or whatever and like
that [ __ ] is like flat you know we were
told Matt Norman like you know Norman
fell again coming central should have
been dying to do his hour mm-hmm with
all the good good work he's done for
them over the years but you can never
expect these people to appreciate you
people appreciate your people you made
laughs the industry doesn't know what's
funny and they
just looking at like what the young
people are looking at like okay that's
what school they don't date they're like
except for there's very cool people and
they're here and they're you're gonna
find like very cool people in like the
industry side of it that you could like
depend on but in general it's it's
[ __ ] they don't you know the dragon's
mouth it's not you can't expect [ __ ]
from it it's it's the [ __ ] uh like
other worries I got anywhere is because
comics yeah that's what sort it sounds
like this that's literally like they
never the industry was never into me and
then for a brief time they we're not and
like you know my career's been over and
done like seven times you know no but
we'll always pay off for you with that
is like if you're funny like people that
know funny will give it to you because
they can't they don't they just can't
it's like it dishonest so they're not -
yeah so you don't have to [ __ ] stress
about we're [ __ ] like a festival or a
contest or if you just don't stress
about that stress about your [ __ ]
jokes I don't know why it's so hard to
write a joke but apparently it is what
you're starting it is it's like even if
you're really funny when you start it's
like I don't know it's like you if you
have to think about walking like one
foot it's it's it's like this weird
thing having a quantify a thing that was
just something you did and and it it's
difficult it makes you like overthink
reflexes yeah then you feel like you
don't have it anymore
because you're trying to figure out what
the [ __ ] like how do I breathe like
you're like it throws you off but
hopefully you get beyond that it's just
it that's the thing man just do you
should I make it really funny and no one
can [ __ ] and say you're not like no one
can and ultimately they that'll save at
you from anything
was your first writing like doing the
comics and things like that my first
writing for like when you were like the
first kind of thing is I would write
jokes for comics here and there that
we're doing roasts locally in like New
York and then the first writing job that
was like they're kind of like oh I got a
red job was Marc Maron I had a show
called Never Mind the Buzzcocks on vh1
for like two minutes
like when Zach Galifianakis had a talk
show oh that Late Show yes get a new
face of the h1 and Never Mind the
Buzzcocks was a British show but I think
it's still on and it was kind of like
the sensibility I liked it's kind of
like a darker sense bill you know Maron
I would see him at the Boston here and
there and I happened to live near him in
Astoria
so I'd like bump into at the supermarket
I didn't know I'm super well but he has
seen me be funny at this and Paul at the
Boston yeah I was watching some show
about Sid Caesar you know like these got
you know cuz log like great [ __ ]
class wrote for that yeah it's like I
used to watch it or something I just
watch the duck is interesting is about
like and it would work like 12-hour days
to do live TV which is very difficult
and um I was like well I've been I could
probably write for something if like
they could do that like I remember
thinking when I say something like I
just happened to like text call Mark and
be like hey man I don't know if you got
that showing you writers but I want to
like submit if I could I know I was like
oh yeah see if you wanted to which was
like just random things I watch this
thing yeah so I'm like and I was like
broke it's always like the same smells
like a dead broke and I got a [ __ ]
like write my way out of it
so I just took today and I just wrote
lines with the kind of vague parameters
of what the show was and they call me
next day like hey he's really funny come
in and I got the job
and then uh it wasn't like it's like 750
a week or something wasn't [ __ ] but it
was it was like more than I was making
which was nothing I know it was better
than a day job and then I was like cool
I'll always like have an income and then
I didn't have any money for like months
yeah
Neal Brennan I would see I was hanging
out with at the Boston I would see him
around I submit for you dinging and he
was like cool yes and then again I
couldn't pay my rent and I was like
living with four dudes in Brooklyn and I
was like we each paid our rent
individually this nice Jewish guy was
funny man cuz like you'd stereotype like
Jewish landlords but he was a very fair
with all this lake and I was a deadbeat
living [ __ ] well Alan his name was
he'd be like coming in to see if I had
my rent
everybody paid there's yeah look his
Kurt and I might just hiding in my room
- I know and then [ __ ] and you'll
called me on three-way with Chappelle
and then they [ __ ] you know I sent me
they wired me the money in advance
because it was like 2500 is sketch so
they wired me five grands I think I
thought [ __ ] Pell do I think it was Neil
that it was that hit Neil's pocket he
did it and then later I never even paid
me all the money back once I got paid
I felt like terribly guilty about it for
years I mean years I felt bad I was like
I finally : like I feel so bad I like I
never
and it was feels like he couldn't
believe I was like just Kurt I made
fifty million dollars sleep
yummy people have not paid me back money
that that I hear let them if you think I
give a [ __ ] about your $5,000 yeah you
know this is like I think it's the main
thing a few knew was like having
perspective is hard mm-hmm and and like
so I don't know that's the thing is
shoot for it's just like how in
perspective collage it seems dire that's
not really dire and trust me much worse
[ __ ] will happen to you and then you'll
rise from the ashes like you have yeah
well it's like if you fight you're gonna
be funny so you can yeah
so so you just gotta like you know at
least they on my fuck-ups or like
national news so so I got a better grade
of fuck-ups mm-hmm I had my storage I
would love to grill you about like all
the amazing comics you've worked with
but I know we've got to land the plane
here because we're about to do our final
show here at the Laughing Skull but I me
being a writer who first and foremost
thinks writing is king and really
respects the pen so much and you being
legitimately like we've worked with some
of the best riders you yourself for one
how not even how like what kind of
advice can you give for like writers and
things like nothing I hate writing I
don't want to [ __ ] deal with I like
doing stand-up but would you write for
yourself and stand-up - yeah but that's
like I'm Ally shall I write on stage and
then just do it again that oh that's how
you do it you don't really write down
just what I'm talking to people and then
something funny happens that I said I
remember to write down a note about it
and then I try to explore it on stage
right and I was good I do it again and I
because I don't want to do work so as
much as I cannot no it's more even like
crab traps out and seeing what crabs I
have in the in the net the next day as
opposed to sitting down because I don't
have that kind of work ethic like that
okay it's just that I'm more idiot
savant than I am totally see that like
you know like you could at the last
minute call me freely I need this this
and this and that's the only time I'm
good really like I'm not good with like
preparation or I'm
down to the wire banging it out I can
tell by working with you this weekend
yes so it's it's like how I did homework
when I was a kid or something like that
the last minute whatever but that's
usually better than if I took my time
and like was responsible wouldn't be as
good people never like this [ __ ] people
like when I have asked the ship people
like is the [ __ ] that I with a lot of
pressure on me because I [ __ ] up I'm
under the gun and then so that's when
the good [ __ ] comes out of me it never
does when I'm being responsible so I
have to treat writing like homework that
I didn't do mmm I have to make it like
the alternate like because I really
accomplished it because I supposed to be
doing something else
so if it becomes my work then I can't do
it so it has to I have to get my mind in
a way where it's the jerk-off thing to
do the job okay not to be professional
it's like my process it's not a good
process and I won't recommend it but
just the only my little survival way so
as far as getting into writing I don't
know man I was in stand-up so that's the
way I went in there's all kinds of like
resources and like pro I don't know
about any of them mm-hmm I was just like
on stage I was funny and then was in New
York I was around people that had [ __ ]
going on so they would let me submit
I've almost never been hired from a
submission except for that Maron thing
mm-hmm but you know let's SNL packets
are out and you get your SN you write it
out like I've almost never been hired
from a thing like that just knowing
people it's being respected on stage
yeah but no Liam is just the foot in the
door and then then they go okay submit
and then they give a [ __ ] about the
submission that's how it's been for me I
don't know how other people do yeah but
if you know any resources take advantage
of it I I don't know man III couldn't I
kind of fell into it so it's not your
goal to do it I don't know what you
should do I would say move to New York
or LA and probably LA over New York
because it'll be more chances of getting
something but as long as you're in a
scene of around comedy and there's
production on stuff around and you're
funny you can get into a kind of easily
you know yeah awesome yeah I was
expecting I guess some sort of like yell
I do this technique and this technique
when I write but you're like well I just
listen when I talk to people and then
pay attention to what's funny about it
yeah I don't have a thing like
report on somebody it's like I have like
I don't know man
I'm also I'm not afraid of failing a lot
like people are afraid to bomb are gonna
not make it and you know you can't be
afraid to suck and like I went to art
school so that my good art teachers like
the things that's interesting as your
failures like your successes aren't that
interesting ooh
so that's gold man yeah but that's
that's like it's true like so because
this it's like the unstructured [ __ ]
before you you know even I would like
draw and sketch and [ __ ] like my roughs
were what we're more interesting than my
finished work right so um I'm not afraid
of it being rough and not like because I
think that's that's what I'm more
interested in looking at a lot of times
that but then you know I also like when
I'd worked on that show with Louie like
it was very interesting to see how he
cuz he's like I mean that guy's like I
mean like even just like comedy but it's
like a genius in in of like getting a
thing done and conceiving a project and
having a dedicated team around and like
we made Horace and Pete that was like if
you had like a friend making a YouTube
thing that everybody just wants to be
Paul yeah so it's cool like it was like
a thing like that but it's like what you
know freaking Jessica Lange and Alan
Alda and Buscemi and you know it's it
was crazy man they were all just like I
was excited to get to work on a thing
so everybody's focused on this guy's
vision and like it's a lot of pressure
I'm sure to have on you but he looked
you know like Woody Allen grand plan
kind of got like yeah well I was very
impressed by that because that's like a
kind of thing I'd never felt I had was
that kind of work ethic or uh after
watching him do it I felt like oh maybe
that's something I could do you know
like it was very like cool to see
somebody things that you think are like
so hard and beyond you like you know
maybe I could do that
Marc said in between takes he would
sometimes come up and like draw dicks on
his script he's funny like you'll think
it's important he knows that you're like
Louie about this right anything like
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
privately just some high school in the
charity all right this looks funny as
[ __ ] Kimber what he wrote to me it was a
[ __ ] you [ __ ] but it's like something
that juvenile right right but builds it
up like he's better drop wisdom and it's
just yeah like or is just some important
note for the scene it's just like a [ __ ]
at your mouth like that is like so funny
but you know that's like impressive man
like somebody like something that's
entertaining you and a guys like that
confident too like [ __ ] around with you
a little bright right yeah so you know I
don't know man that's like why you you
just like mostly sure you learn by doing
it mm-hmm so if you want to be a writer
just start [ __ ] writing and then
[ __ ] as I've done every time I didn't
have something I just started working on
something I just made up that wasn't
gonna go anywhere but the act of doing
that
I don't know triggered something that
made other things happen so I'm so glad
we could make this happen I know the so
before we get out of here is there
anything else you want the world to know
when my hour comes out please buy it on
Louie's website it's called you're
making it worse and I think we're
shooting it in August or September nice
and he's backing and he's like putting
on his website and everything that's
awesome
yeah well literally no one else was
interested in doing my hour with me I'm
not one not one place wanted to do it
Wow yeah I mean he want to do it like a
while ago before any that should happen
but that is that's how they shoot it
because besides being away male like I
had my reap apologist to fit like a
little bet I don't know whatever that
scene is man I hope they [ __ ] pull
their heads out of their asses because I
or else I hope you like a nice long
Trump administration because that
[ __ ] rigid almost religious
liberalism but without like the love of
Jesus on every level is not getting you
nowhere
it's gonna make things real bad and
since you're the Liberals and you're
smarter it's on you to change not the
rubes
the rubes we're gonna end on the word
the rubes kurt metzger thank you so much
for taking the time I know it's finding
time with you can be very difficult uh
cliche stand down in this little bit
here man
[Music]
I breath